لم يكن العنف الحالي بين
الإسرائيليين والفلسطينيين
بهذا السوء
لسنوات عديدة مع تحذير الأمم المتحدة من
أن الصراع يمكن أن يتصاعد
إلى حرب واسعة النطاق ، ولكن كيف
انفجر الوضع
فجأة الإخلاء المقترح
للعديد من العائلات الفلسطينية من
حي الشيخ جراح
في  القدس الشرقية هي أحد العوامل
الدافعة لأحدث أعمال العنف
التي يعيشونها في المنطقة منذ عام
، وأثارت إمكانية الإخلاء
انتقادات دولية واحتجاجًا
أدى إلى إصابة 22 فلسطينيًا بجروح
عندما تحركت الشرطة الإسرائيلية لتطهير
طريق
واشتبكت الشرطة الإسرائيلية مع الفلسطينيين
بعد ذلك.  صلاة الجمعة
في المسجد الأقصى المبني على
مجمع
معروف للمسلمين بأنه الحرم النبيل
ولليهود
كما جبل المعبد هو واحد من
أقدس الأماكن في المدينة
لكلا الديانتين أطلقت الشرطة الإسرائيلية
قنابل الصوت
داخل المسجد نفسه بينما
ألقى الفلسطينيون  وأصيب
ما يصل إلى 205
فلسطينيين بالحجارة في أعمال عنف
بعد يومين في إسرائيل  أجلت المحكمة العليا في إيلي
قرارا بإجلاء
العائلات الفلسطينية من منازلهم
، وتم تغيير مسار موكب يوم القدس
لمحاولة تجنب
المزيد من المواجهات ، حيث أطلقت صافرات الإنذار في
القدس الساعة 6 مساءً
حيث أطلقت الجماعات المسلحة في غزة ، وهي حماس
والجهاد الإسلامي ستة صواريخ على
ردا على تصرفات الشرطة الإسرائيلية ،
شنت إسرائيل غارات جوية على
غزة واستدعت سبعة آلاف من
جنود الاحتياط
في الخدمة الفعلية ، وابل من الصواريخ على مدار اليوم
من غزة
قصفت المدن الإسرائيلية بما في ذلك تل
أبيب
مما أجبر
مطار
بن  - تم إطلاق
أكثر من 3000
صاروخ على إسرائيل وقتل ما لا يقل عن 12
شخصًا وفقًا لحملة قصف جيش الدفاع الإسرائيلي
في غزة مما
أسفر عن مقتل أكثر من 200
شخص وإصابة مئات آخرين وفقًا
لوزارة غزة التي تديرها حماس.  الصحة
ما لا يقل عن 61 من القتلى أطفال
تزعم إسرائيل أن أكثر من مائة
مقاتل قتلوا
كانت هناك إدانات دولية
متجمعة
ولكن وضع حد للعنف يبدو أنه من
الصعب على نحو متزايد أن
تلعب العوامل الدينية والقومية السياسية دورًا ، ومع اشتداد الوضع
في الضفة الغربية وغزة ،
هناك قلق متزايد من أن
العنف قد ينتشر
أكثر
[  موسيقى]
أنت